Transcriptor: Juliana Marín
Revisor: Lily María Bello Sánchez
Siempre me fasciné con el poder
y convicción de estas personas
que tienen esa gran capacidad
de levantarse de los fracasos,
de los desastres, ponerse en pie
y continuar la marcha.
O aquellos que tienen esa fuerza increíble
de enfrentarse a todos los imposibles.
Los que marchan con causas
y con propuestas
y las defienden a pesar
de todas las circunstancias.
La historia de la humanidad tiene
bellísimos y maravillosos ejemplos.
Yo, sin embargo, me atrevo esta tarde
a hablarles de un ejemplo
que marcó mi vida desde mi niñez.
Mi padre murió cuando
yo tenía cerca de 3 años de edad.
Mi madre quedó viuda, sola, obviamente,
con nueve niños y niñas muy pequeños.
La gran mayoría eran pequeñitos
y una niña, un bebé de brazos.
Ese golpe fatal a la familia y en especial
para mi madre fue muy duro.
Cuando yo crecí, a pesar de que
tengo vagos recuerdos,
cuando crecí comencé a enfrentar
mis propias dificultades,
siempre me quedó en la memoria
cómo habrá sido esa mañana.
Cómo hizo mi madre
para levantarse esa mañana
después de la muerte de mi padre.
Es decir, estaba abatida, dolida,
su mundo se había derrumbado.
¿Qué aliciente podría tener?
¿Qué fuerza la movió
a ponerse de pie y volver a comenzar?
A lo largo de mi vida he tenido
muchísimas dificultades,
muchísimos momentos
inclusive de abatimiento total,
como seguro muchos de ustedes.
Esos momentos donde uno
no se siente capaz de seguir,
donde uno cree que ya llegó
hasta el fin de lo que podía hacer.
Pero siempre me repito incansablemente:
“Si ella fue capaz
de levantarse esa mañana,
tú tienes que ser capaz
de levantarte ahora, ¡ya!",
"en este instante Juangui,
¡de pie! Vamos pa' delante".
"Por respeto y honor a ella
no puedes ser menor en tus esfuerzos”.
Y en el tiempo,
cuando fue pasando el tiempo,
empecé a atar cabos y a darme cuenta
de que todos tenemos una fuerza interior,
y que esa fuerza interior
se activa con un desafío,
y ese desafío debe ser esperanzador,
lo que yo llamo:
“La Fuerza de la Esperanza”.
En los próximos minutos
voy a compartir con ustedes
cómo esta experiencia de vida
me llevó a desarrollar estrategias
para hacer que niños y jóvenes
pudieran encontrar
su propia Fuerza de la Esperanza,
y también a entender que no se trata de
la pobreza externa y la situación social,
sino de la riqueza interior,
con la que podemos
solucionar muchas cosas,
independiente de cuál sea
nuestra condición social.
Quiero hacer un planteamiento
de todas maneras
para tener un punto de partida
y dar a entender dónde encaja
cada una de estas cosas.
La pobreza, el hambre,
las injusticias sociales
son provocadoras de grandes conflictos
y engendran en ellas
insospechadas maneras de violencia.
Esa es una realidad,
cruda como es, pero la es.
Sin embargo, en esa misma situación,
esa misma situación puede ser
el caldo de cultivo perfecto
o el terreno abonado para una profunda
transformación humana y social.
Son como dos caras de una misma moneda,
son dos visiones de la misma situación.
Una ve el problema, la otra ve
en ese problema una oportunidad.
Para poder llevarlos al contexto
de dónde juegan estas
tres palabras tan importantes:
fuerza interior, desafío y esperanza,
voy a presentarles, entonces,
el cuadro real.
En esa primera situación tenemos:
¿de qué está compuesta?
Pues, primero que todo
de la complicación social,
de la pobreza, de la falta de empleo,
la falta de estudio, de la violencia,
de la descomposición social
en todos los términos.
Esa es una realidad.
Pasemos la página
y vámonos a la oportunidad.
Lo que tenemos en
esa misma situación social
es que cada uno de esos niños y jóvenes
que habita en esas circunstancias
tiene una fuerza interior
que desconoce,
que la desconoce,
en la mayoría de los casos.
Tiene una fuerza interior.
Una fuerza interior que es un instinto
que se activa con la esperanza,
con el desafío y con la esperanza.
Pero no hablo de la esperanza
en la solución del conflicto,
no en la esperanza
de que en el día de mañana
todo va a ser coloradito y muy bonito
y entonces vamos a
poder tener todos oportunidades.
En la esperanza que hablo de ellos es
que cada uno tiene un deseo de superación,
cada uno individualmente
aspira a algo más.
A salir adelante, a proyectarse al mundo.
Imagínense ese tesoro.
Solamente la fuerza interior en cada uno
y un deseo de superación.
¡Es algo maravilloso!
Es algo maravilloso con lo que
podemos empezar a trabajar.
La fuerza interior es un instinto.
Es un instinto animal,
ancestral, de supervivencia.
La fuerza interior cuando
es desatada, cuando es activada
o la despierta la esperanza, el desafío
y esa esperanza, entonces
te devuelve la confianza en ti mismo,
te dota de una fortaleza
y una seguridad especial, maravillosas,
y también te dota de capacidades
por encima de lo imaginable.
El desafío es algo,
y aquí voy a hacer la advertencia:
no se te ocurra despertar en un niño
o en un joven la fuerza interior
si no lo vas a desafiar a algo
por encima de sus capacidades,
porque ahí es donde nos enfrentamos
a la competencia, la delincuencia,
que son los mismos que generan
terror y zozobra en las comunidades,
y que son aquellos que
se roban a los niños, que los envician,
que los vuelven consumidores,
que los atraen con cosas vacías,
los desafían al dinero
y a los objetivos vanos, vacíos.
Esa misma delincuencia utiliza el poder,
la fuerza de la esperanza,
para volverlos malos, para engañarlos.
Entonces ese desafío tiene que ser
no solo por encima de sus capacidades
sino un desafío con esperanza.
Y para hablar de la esperanza:
ahí están viendo algunas de las fotos
de los barrios de Medellín
donde hemos trabajado por muchos años,
por cerca de 30 años o un poquito más.
Porque es la mejor manera
de expresar la esperanza,
y estos tres factores,
la fuerza interior y el desafío.
A finales de los años 80
y principios de los 90
nos fuimos a los barrios de Medellín
a desafiar a los niños con instrumentos
musicales sinfónicos.
Es decir, un Desafío que no solo estaba
por encima sus capacidades en ese momento,
sino que era un desafío
inclusive para nosotros
porque lo que menos querían
en las comunas de Medellín
era música clásica
e instrumentos sinfónicos.
Había una brecha lamentable,
no solamente social sino cultural,
para ellos esa era la música
y los instrumentos de los de allá,
de los ricos y más pudientes,
y no la música de ellos.
En fin, logramos llegar a las comunidades
y habíamos ganado espacio,
y nos dieron la oportunidad
de comenzar a hacer
esta tarea desafiante pero maravillosa.
En muy corto tiempo los niños
estaban llenando las Escuelas de Música.
Era como su segundo hogar.
Allí iban a pasar todo el tiempo,
no solo a practicar sus instrumentos,
sino también a hacer sus tareas,
a compartir con sus compañeros.
Rápidamente pusimos un desafío inmenso
que era alcanzar un nivel musical
como nunca se había hecho
en el país, en todos los tiempos.
O ellos eran capaces de eso
o estábamos perdiendo el tiempo.
Y ellos se sumaron a ese desafío.
Y eran instrumentos sinfónicos que también
rompieron un paradigma en la historia,
que tenían que empezar a cierta edad
o con ciertas capacidades.
Aquí hubo lo mismo para todos.
Les hago breve la historia,
el tema avanzó tan abruptamente,
tan vertiginosamente,
que en poco tiempo teníamos
ese nivel musical y mucho más allá,
y entonces nos pusimos
un desafío más allá:
que había que salir a Europa
a tocar música europea para los europeos
allá donde ellos la hicieron,
y desafiar y mostrar que unos niños
pobres a lo mejor, o humildes,
de la ciudad de Medellín,
con sus jeans rotos y sus zapatos rotos,
con instrumentos de palo y de lata,
porque no teníamos instrumentos
finos o de calidad,
podían hacer mucho más con la música
de lo que los demás se podían imaginar,
solo con esa fuerza interior
y esa gran capacidad de convicción.
Y de verdad llegaron,
en muchos lugares en España, en Italia,
tocaron en palacios, en teatros,
en escenarios, llegaron al Vaticano,
que es esta foto que ven ahí,
a tocar para el Papa Juan Pablo II.
Eso yo creo que es un imposible,
yo no creo que eso se vea todos los días
y se haga todos los días,
que niños de los barrios de la ciudad
tengan esa oportunidad en cada momento.
Pero se la ganaron trabajando,
mostrando de lo que están hechos
y de lo que son capaces de hacer.
Y ocurrió un fenómeno algo curioso.
La televisión italiana,
nosotros no sabíamos,
transmitió el concierto del Papa
en directo para el mundo
con señal gratuita para todos los países.
Nosotros no teníamos ni idea.
No sabíamos ni como habíamos llegado allá,
mucho menos íbamos a saber
cómo estaban transmitiendo eso.
El hecho es que antes de salir
nadie nos creyó.
Nadie les creyó a los niños
que iban a tocar para el Papa.
Entonces nadie realmente nos acompañó
de los medios de comunicación.
Tuvimos que llevar unos periodistas
propios para grabar por lo menos imágenes
para que quedaran en la historia.
Un mundo un poco solitario.
Lo curioso es que como la señal
era gratuita y para todo el mundo,
en Colombia se despertó el país
con la señal de estos niños,
una orquestica pequeñita
de apenas 160 integrantes,
y se despertó el país con estas imágenes
en televisión, y la emoción,
y los medios de comunicación
comenzaron a llamar,
y yo con ganas de decir:
"Pero si nosotros les dijimos
que veníamos para donde el Papa".
“Sí, pero es que ¡eso es imposible!”.
Y yo, "¿Sí? Yo no sé,
¡pero aquí estamos!".
(Risas)
Este es el Papa pues... yo no sé...
"O yo le pregunto si necesita...
O le paso el celular pues como para que…".
Y al mismo tiempo la señal
llegó a otros lugares.
Y al día siguiente, tenían que salir
los chicos a tocar en Venecia
para la inauguración de una exposición
de esculturas y pinturas del
maestro Fernando Botero.
Cuando llegamos a Venecia
estos se me volaron, se me escaparon,
yo no sabía dónde estaban,
y salí corriendo a buscarlos
cuando estaban muy tranquilos,
muy cómodos en la Plaza de San Marcos,
porque la gente los había visto
en televisión ante el Papa
y pensaron que eran muy famosos
y que era una novedad tenerlos en Venecia,
y ellos estaban felices firmando
autógrafos y tomándose fotos,
y yo: “Oigan, ¿y ustedes qué?".
“Juangui, firmando autógrafos hermano,
somos muy famosos en Venecia",
y no habían llegado
a estar allá en su vida.
Esos mismos niños, despiertos, inquietos,
necios, que se suben por todas partes,
que cuando los soltamos
no hay manera de controlarlos,
los mismos ingenuos, inocentes,
seres maravillosos,
cuando abrimos la habitación de un hotel
había cuatro metidos en una bañera,
porque era la primera vez
que veían una bañera.
Había otros que no se habían podido bañar
porque no sabían abrir las llaves.
Y no faltó quien obviamente logró
después de muchos esfuerzos
abrir la llavecita de
debajo de la bañera y no la ducha,
entonces se dobló agachado ahí,
en una manera un poco incómoda
para poderse bañar.
O el que salió del mar
un poco decepcionado y me dijo:
“Juangui, ¡esa agua
es muy salada hermano!”.
(Risas)
O el niño que llegó tarde
a uno de los ensayos
y cuando le pedimos que nos explicara
qué había pasado, llorando nos dijo:
“Es que mi hermano y yo
tenemos un solo bluyín,
y mi hermano se madrugó
para un paseo y se llevó el bluyín”.
Es decir, un contraste de cosas
fascinantes, maravillosas.
Estos mismos niños
eran capaces de hacer todo eso
que, para nosotros, los demás,
son imposibles.
Y la pregunta del millón es esa:
¿Cómo lo hicieron?
¿Cómo se logró todo eso?
¿Cómo fueron capaces de lograrlo?
Y la respuesta es: “Como no sabían
que era imposible, lo hicieron”.
Nunca supieron que fuera imposible.
Ahora, para explicar la fuerza interior,
la esperanza, el desafío,
no fueron los imposibles
los que los movieron a ellos a hacerlo,
fue la fuerza interior,
la fuerza de la esperanza en cada uno,
porque ellos desconocían los imposibles.
Ahí tienen la foto de esa
pequeña orquesta que viajó
y que fueron pioneros,
llegaron a donde ninguna orquesta
juvenil o profesional en esa época
había llegado antes.
Luego vienen otras generaciones,
y más generaciones de niños
con los que estamos tratando de llegar
en barrios y veredas
a llevar esa fuerza de la esperanza,
y que cada uno pueda ver un mundo mejor.
La fuerza de la esperanza es
como un leño encendido todavía,
en lo más profundo de tu ser.
¿Ustedes pueden imaginarse lo que ve
un niño en medio de la pobreza,
de la violencia y de la
descomposición social?
Ustedes se imaginan ese niño rodeado,
cercado de esas condiciones,
¿a dónde apunta? ¿Qué ve? No ve nada.
Abandona sus sueños, sus ilusiones,
y se ve negado a todas
las posibilidades y oportunidades
porque piensa que nació en un mundo
totalmente adverso a él,
sin ninguna razón,
como si tuviera una culpa.
Pero desconoce que tiene
esa fuerza interior,
así como nosotros también.
Que hay momentos,
pese a que tenemos una vida mejor,
hay momentos de cansancio,
hay momentos donde queremos
tirar la toalla y claudicar.
Pues hay un leño encendido
en lo más profundo de tu ser,
hay un leño que no te abandona.
Las cosas afuera, externas,
se pueden poner de cualquier manera,
pero internamente
ese leño permanece encendido.
Tal vez oculto, bajo las cenizas,
tal vez silencioso, inerte,
pero está allí cuidando el tesoro
de capacidades y posibilidades
que en un momento dado
vas a necesitar para dar ese paso final,
para salir de la adversidad,
para llenarte de aire,
tomar una gran bocanada
y salir a la superficie
y llegar más lejos.
Imagínense entonces con esta foto,
donde se comprimen miles de vidas
y de historias de niños
que tuvieron la oportunidad de vivir
y de sentir esa fuerza interior.
Muchos no sé dónde están,
otros ya dejaron la música,
ya siguieron por sus propios caminos,
lo que quiero decir
con esta foto es que todos,
independiente donde estén
y lo que sean son gente de bien,
son personas responsables,
trabajadoras, que inspiran a otros,
que su vida cambió
y ayudan a cambiar el mundo.
¿Se imaginan miles y miles de niños más
viviendo y conociendo
la fuerza de la esperanza?
¿Te imaginas niños, miles en veredas,
en barrios, en ciudades,
que puedan vivir,
ver el mundo como tú y yo?
¿Sentir el mundo y sentir la vida
y las oportunidades?
¿Tú te imaginas el poder
de la fuerza de la esperanza?
Es fácil.
Ellos ponen la fuerza interior
y nosotros solo ponemos la esperanza.
Dicen que la esperanza
es lo último que se pierde.
No, no. La esperanza es lo último
que queda cuando todo está acabado.
Por eso se llama esperanza,
porque no se pierde nunca.
¡La fuerza de la esperanza es
la fuerza de Dios en nosotros!
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)